good morning John so the team at scishow
is constantly looking for images to use
for thumbnails and graphics and stuff
and they're always finding very strange
things on stock photography sites and I
decided that I would share some of the
things that they have found and also
some things that I have found along with
some captions that people sent to me on
Twitter and here it all is John have a
good time with this thing that I decided
to do right before I left for London I
don't know what I'm thinking let's do it
the doc said rubbing my knee daily would
get rid of the weird old lady face that
it has inside of it look Steven I'm just
gonna say you you really don't look very
much like your tinder profile pic and
like I also play the game I get it but
uh I mean thanks for taking me to the
beach anyway today announcing their run
for the President of the United States a
new candidate which we find ourselves
somewhat surprised to realize we would
indeed vote for this is the best
gender-reveal party I've ever been to it
is not GU Rican CHR unless your metaphor
works on at least a three different
levels Gary I swear to you you can order
these mark turtlenecks at Lands End com
you do not need a physical catalog that
moment when you've been promoted to
Admiral but everybody's still treating
you like a colonel while we do applaud
your creativity Brenda I'm afraid that
your submission to the Northland
elementary school mascot design contest
has been rejected are you ready to hear
about my breading night adventures even
my facade is a facade mom I mean in all
honesty we probably should have checked
out the Yelp reviews before visiting the
island of dr. Moreau I think this one
might really be on us Gary talk to the
hand
because the hand is actually my face and
that's the polite thing obviously they
polite thing to do don't worry honey I
saw this in a movie we're gonna be fine
treat yourself
Oh what about a meet yourself yeah I
think you've got sausage fingers I know
right now it seems like you're a winter
but trust me five more minutes on the
grill and you'll be an autumn it's not a
very big car but it's very big
move they say there's a lot of fish in
the sea I say there's a lot of keys in
the desert I'm a lock dude this is the
last time you cannot keep searching
Google images for headlights at work
well it's 9 o'clock on a Caturday and a
cat get some cream for his tea I'm
eating a bar of white chocolates and
those muffins for Fuffy and me a loofah
sponge on my you know I think the real
pregnant dancing men with the stock
photos we captioned along the way okay
that's all I had John I'll see you on
Tuesday I won't the real Slim Shady
please stand up please stand up please
stand up